.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN BACK IN
WASHINGTON TRYING TO WALK BACK
HIS AD-LIBBED REMARK.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED YOU AND
OTHER ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
MAY BE UNDERMINING HIM ON THE
WORLD STAGE.
>> Laura: I TOLD YOU IT WAS
A MISTAKE FOR THE WHITE HOUSE TO
SEND BIDEN TO EUROPE.
IF HE THINKS THESE APPEARANCES
WILL BOOST HIM HE HAS ANOTHER
THINK COMING.
BIDEN SHOULD HAVE PARTICIPATED
OVER ZOOM.
THE MAN IS INCOHERENT ENOUGH
WITHOUT JET LAG.
"ANGLE" WAS CORRECT.
BIDEN WAS A HUMAN WRECKING BALL.
ASKED ABOUT REPORTS THAT RUSSIA
MIGHT USE CHEMICAL WEAPONS IN
UKRAINE HE SAID THE U.S. WOULD
RESPOND IN KIND.
MACRON WARNED ABOUT THE WITH THE
ESCALATING THINGS SO THE WHITE
HOUSE HAD TO DO ITS FAVORITE
DANCE CALLED THE WALK BACK.
>> THE U.S. WON'T USE CHEMICAL
WEAPONS UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> WITH THE RESPECT OF ANY
WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION,
RUSSIA WOULD PAY A SEVERE PRICE.
>> Laura: IN-KIND MEANS SEVERE
RESPONSE.
IN POLAND BIDEN ANNOUNCED A 180
DEGREE CHANGE IN POLICY AFTER
INSISTING THERE WOULD BE NO U.S.
BOOTS ON THE GROUND IN UKRAINE.
>> YOU WILL SEE WHEN YOU ARE
THERE.
YOU WILL SEE WOMEN, YOUNG PEOPLE
STANDING IN FRONT OF A TANK
SAYING I AM NOT LEAVING.
>> Laura: AGAIN HIS STAFF HAD TO
SCRAMBLE.
A WHITE HOUSE SPOKESPERSON TRIED
TO CLARIFY THE PRESIDENT'S
REMARKS SAYING THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN CLEAR, WE ARE NOT SENDING
U.S. TROOPS TO UKRAINE.
THE MOST DANGEROUS FLUB HEARD
AROUND THE WORLD WERE HIS AD-LIB
COMMENTS ON PUTIN.
>> UKRAINE WILL NEVER BE PART OF
RUSSIA.
THIS MAN CANNOT REMAIN IN POWER.
>> Laura: WHY IS HE ALWAYS
SCREAMING?
THIS WAS ANOTHER INSTANCE OF
BIDEN PLAYING PUNDIT INSTEAD OF
ACTING LIKE A PRESIDENT.
TARGETING PUTIN PLAYS INTO HIS
HANDS BOOSTING PROPAGANDA
EFFORTS IN MOTHER RUSSIA.
REAGAN NEVER SAID THIS DURING
THE DARKEST DAYS OF THE COLD
WAR.
BIDEN DISMISSED ANY FALLOUT
PLAYING CLEAN UP MAN FOR
HIMSELF.
>> YOU HAVE MORE FOREIGN POLICY
EXPERIENCE MORE THAN ANY
PRESIDENT.
YOU UNDERSTAND WHY SOMEONE WOULD
BELIEVE YOU SAYING SOMEONE CAN'T
REMAIN IN POWER.
THAT'S A STATEMENT OF U.S.
POLICY.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT
PROPAGANDA USE OF THOSE REMARKS
BY THE RUSSIANS?
>> NO AND NO.
NOBODY BELIEVES WE WILL TAKE
DOWN PUTIN.
I WAS EXPRESSING BY OUTRAGE.
>> Laura: EVERY TIME THEY SEND
BIDEN OUT TO SPEAK HE DIGS
HIMSELF AND AMERICA INTO
A DEEPER HOLE.
IT HAPPENS EVERY TIME.
TODAY WAS SUPPOSED TO BE HIS
CHANCE TO REASSURE ALLIES AFTER
HIS SPEECH LAST WEEK.
HE STILL COULD NOT GET IT RIGHT
AND THINGS WENT SIDE WAYS.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE WHAT YOU SAID
THAT PUTIN CAN'T REMAIN IN
POWER?
>> I AM NOT WALKING ANYTHING
BACK.
I WAS EXPRESSING THE MORAL
OUTRAGE I FELT TOWARD THE WAY
PUTIN IS DEALING AND THE ACTIONS
OF THIS MAN.
JUST BRUTALITY.
I AM NOT ARTICULATING A POLICY
CHANGE.
I MAKE NO APOLOGIES FOR IT.
>> Laura: IT'S REALLY CONFUSING
FOR JOE AND HIS TEAM.
THEY HAD TO WALK BACK HIS
NON-WALK-BACK.
>> IT SOUNDED LIKE YOU TOLD U.S.
TROOPS THEY WERE GO TO UKRAINE.
>> YOU INTERPRETED IT THAT WAY.
TALKING ABOUT HELPING TRAIN THE
UKRAINIAN TROOPS IN POLAND.
>> WHEN YOU SAID YOU ARE GOING
TO SEE WHEN YOU ARE THERE?
>> I WAS TALKING WITH THE
UKRAINIAN TROOPS THAT WERE IN
POLAND.
>> Laura: THIS WOULD BE
A DANGEROUS ESCALATION.
REACHED FOR COMMENT BY POLITICO
A PENTAGON SPOKESPERSON DID NOT
RESPOND NOR DID REPRESENTATIVES
FOR THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT.
THE WHITE HOUSE GOT THE SWIFFER
BACK OUT SAYING THERE ARE
UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS IN POLAND
INTERACTING WITH U.S. TROOPS.
THIS HAS GONE FROM SAD TO SCARY.
HE IS NOT AN ORDINARY CITIZEN.
THIS IS A SENSITIVE SITUATION.
EVERY WORD AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT
UTTERS HAS GLOBAL REPERCUSSIONS.
HE IS NOT CAPABLE OF
FREELANCING.
NEVERTHELESS, THE PEOPLE AT CNN
TRIED TO HELP THE CLEAN UP
MISSION.
>> HE WAS SPEAKING OUT OF
FRUSTRATION AND ANGER.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT RESPONDING
WITH EMOTIONS HERE.
>> CANDOR IS UNAPPRECIATED IN
DIPLOMACY.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO CAN BE
CANDID AND TELL YOU WHAT ME IS
THINKING.
HE IS HUGGING CHILDREN WHO LOST
THEIR PARENTS AND HAVE SEEN
DEATH.
THAT'S WHAT HE WAS REFLECTING.
IT WAS NOT A POLICY CHANGE.
WE ARE NOT USED TO PRESIDENTS
WHO DO THAT.
>> Laura: YES, GLORIA.
THAT'S THE CONCERN.
BIDEN IS TOO CANDID.
A FORMER CIA DIRECTOR.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT
BIDEN MADE THAT MISTAKE?
>> I HAPPEN TO THINK THAT JOE
BIDEN IS IRISH.
HE HAS A GREAT DEAL OF
COMPASSION WHEN HE SEES THAT
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING.
I THINK IT OVERWHELMED HIM.
>> Laura: HE SAID IT'S BECAUSE
BIDEN IS IRISH.
TRAFFICKING IN EMOTIONALISM WITH
PUTIN COULD MAKE LIFE MORE
PAINFUL FOR THE UKRAINIANS
GIVING PUTIN AN EXCUSE TO RAMP
THINGS UP.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME JOE'S
CLEAN UP CREW USED HIS EMPATHY
TO EXCUSE A MAJOR DIPLOMATIC
MISTAKE.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S REMARKS SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES.
HE WAS SPEAKING FROM HIS HEART.
>> Laura: EVEN THE LEFT KNOWS
BIDEN MADE A MISTAKE IN POLAND.
LOOK AT THIS HEADLINE.
FROM DAY 1, IT WAS OBVIOUS THAT
THE ENTIRE RATIONALE FOR THIS
TRIP WAS POLITICAL.
THE WHITE HOUSE HOPED THAT
SEEING BIDEN ON THE
INTERNATIONAL STAGE WOULD
DISTRACT VOTERS AT HOME FROM THE
ECONOMY.
THE OPPOSITE HAPPENED.
THE RESULTS OF THE NEW NBC POLL
ARE NIGHTMARISH.
>> BY A LARGE 71-28% MARGIN
AMERICANS DO NOT HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE IN PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
ABILITY TO RESPOND TO THIS WAR.
57% SAID WE ARE ALREADY AT WAR
WITH RUSSIA OR WILL BE WITHIN
A YEAR.
AND 68% WOULD PREFER MR. BIDEN
MAKE THE ECONOMY HIS TOP
PRIORITY.
HIS JOB APPROVAL IS JUST 40%
WITH 55% DISAPPROVAL.
HIS WORST SHOWING SINCE HE
BECAME PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: IF YOU PUT
A MICROPHONE IN FRONT OF BIDEN
HE IS BOUND TO SAY ANYTHING THAT
POPS INTO HIS MIND.
HE WAS OBAMA'S VP NO ONE TOOK
HIM SERIOUSLY NOT EVEN OBAMA.
NOW AS PRESIDENT.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
SELF-DISCIPLINE TO WEIGH HIS
WORDS MORE CAREFULLY.
HE UNDERMINES THE EFFORTS THAT
HIS ADMINISTRATION IS MAKEING TO
KEEP EUROPE ON OUR SIDE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THE MAJOR NATO
COUNTRIES HAVE NO INTEREST IN
FORCING REGIME CHANGE IN RUSSIA.
BIDEN THINKS APPEALING TO THE
PRESS CORP MATTERS MOST.
THE WHITE HOUSE KEEPS HOPING FOR
A GEORGE W. BUSH MOMENT WITH THE
BULL HORN.
THAT THIS CRISIS IN UKRAINE WILL
HELP HIS PARTY IN THE MID-TERMS
LIKE IT HELPED REPUBLICANS IN
2002.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED THIS REMARK
MIGHT ESCALATE THE CONFLICT?
>> NO, I AM NOT AT ALL.
NATO HAS EVER, EVER, EVER BEEN
AS STRONG AS IT IS TODAY.
NEVER.
>> Laura: NEVER.
THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT NO ONE
INSIDE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS A CLEAR STRATEGY ABOUT WHAT
WE ARE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH AND
HOW TO ADVANCE OUR INTERESTS IN
A PRUDENT MANNER.
THE ONLY STRATEGY IS TO KEEP THE
MEDIA HAPPY AND HOPE FOR A RALLY
AROUND THE FLAG MOMENTUM GOING
INTO NOVEMBER.
ALL OF THEIR TIME AND EFFORT IS
EATEN UP WITH THEIR SPIN
CAMPAIGN.
THEY DID THE SAME THING LEADING
UP TO THE AFGHAN WITHDRAWAL.
WE KNOW HOW THAT ENDED.
THEY KEEP GETTING THIS WRONG.
IT'S UNREAL TO WATCH THIS.
THE WAY TO FIX YOUR POLL
NUMBERS, JOE, IS NOT TO SHOWCASE
AMERICA'S WEAKNESS AND GET
BOGGED DOWN IN EUROPE.
THE WAY TO FIX YOUR POLL NUMBERS
IS TO MAKE AMERICA STRONGER.
THAT MEANS A DOMESTIC POLICY BY
NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER
THAT WILL ONLY DELIVERY MORE
MISERY FOR MORE PEOPLE.
TRYING TO CLEAN THAT UP WILL BE
LEFT TO THE REPUBLICANS WHO END
UP TROUNCING THE